From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
We're running.
Good afternoon.
Today is April 16, 2013.
April 15.
April 50, 2013.
Thank you.
And today we are in Palo Alto, California on behalf of the Civil Rights History Project.
Supported by the Congress, the Library of Congress, the Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture.
And this project is also supported by the Southern Oral History Program at UNC Chapel Hill.
My name is David Kline over the interviewer today.
With me is videographer John Bishop of Media Generation and UCLA.
And we have with us today Dr. Clarence Jones and I just want to say thank you so much for spending time with us today.
My pleasure.
Thank you.
I'm glad to be here.
I just out of deference to my mother.
I'd like for you to use my middle initial when you were putting it in the archives.
Clarence B. Jones.
My mother's name is Benjamin.
And so that she seemed to be very much indeed to that name.
So as an adult I've carried it forward.
Wonderful.
Okay.
Let me understand that.
And so let's start there.
Okay.
With your birth parents and a little bit about your childhood.
Where that brought you?
My parents were domestic servants when I was born.
I was born over 82 years ago, 82 years ago this January, this past January, 1931 in Philadelphia, Pennsylvania.
When I said my parents were domestic workers, specifically my mother was a maiden of cook.
My father was a chauffeur and a gardener.
And they worked as a domestic servant couple for J.B. Lippincott family of the J.B. Lippincott family.
J.B. Lippincott family out of Philadelphia and into publishing into a grain.
But a very established wealthy family.
And J.B. Lippincott family was one of the grandums of the family, who employed my parents.
When I was born, apparently they did not have a home of their own.
So the home in which I came into was the home of the place where they worked.
And I can remember before the age of about six years of age, being placed at least with three different foster families.
And by that I mean these were adult friends of my parents, who my parents had made some arrangements.
I guess you will keep young clearance, let them stay as part of the family.
And so that's I was I was I was place with them, different families.
This happened at least on three occasions before about the age of six years of age.
Again I don't know what prompted my mother and father to do it principally my mother.
Decided that they would place me in a boarding school, a boarding school for foster children and orphans.
Or specifically for indigent foster and orphan colored boys and Indians run by the Sisters of the Blessed Sacrament.
And I think also by the order of the sacred heart, the nuns who ran the religious order that ran the Catholic boarding school for colored boys.
Orphans and foster children also maintain mission schools in New Mexico on the Navajo reservations.
And as a consequence, as a young boy in this boarding school for colored and indigent children.
Several of the boys there were Indians.
And very early on I would I got accustomed to seeing a boy with long, long, big tail.
You know, long ponytail or something. This hair would be knotted or braided.
And the feather of band. And I remember classmates of mine, people in the school having names like Little Bear and Running Bear.
And something dear. Those are their names. That's where I stayed from about the age of six years away.
This was a Catholic private boarding school. The interesting thing about this, you notice I said there were foster children and orphans. I was neither. I had parents.
It became clear to me that there was something wasn't right here, little contradiction because what would happen. I was there from about the age of six until 13, almost 14.
My parents would come to visit me and they would leave. And some of the other boys would say to me, well, why are you here? Why don't they take you with them?
And very hard for a young person to understand it.
During the summers, I spent three or four weeks in the summer with my parents wherever they, in the summer they usually, the woman they worked for, took a house as a summer house in Jersey Shore.
And a place called Longport, your Margate and Atlantic City. So they would be there all summer and I would go down and visit them during the summer. So I had that break.
That's the only time you would actually stay with them.
Yes, that's the only time. I didn't have Christmas with them. Didn't have Easter, didn't have holidays with them. But during this holidays I had with them. I mean, I took the summer.
And you know, when I was in about the sixth, when I was in about the seventh grade, six of the seventh grade I developed a serious stuttering problem.
And it was a surprise. I couldn't understand why I had begun to stammer.
And I think as I look back on it, and as I moved on to public high school with the help of a speech teacher and just different kind of pressures operating on me, I guess.
I was able to overcome the stammering. You wouldn't know that I studied the stammering way I speak now, the way I have spoken. So my, but the fact is, and I look back on it, I think it was that not understanding.
Now, someone might listen to this story and have a certain degree of a,
a degree of a, pathos and say, you know, I must, it's a sad thing that Master Jones, a little boy went through before. Yes and no.
As I've gotten older, I am without question, I knew I was cared for and loved.
Those Irish nuns loved me. They were my surrogate mothers. They loved me and had a, with a sense of discipline, you know, that stayed with me during my formative years.
I put it this way. Had I not gone to that Catholic boarding school, I probably would have been placed in a, a, a, a de jury or meaning by law or de facto segregated school.
And I probably would have gotten an inferior education compared to the education I actually received because as a result of going to this Catholic boarding school, there are classes of maybe about 25 boys, but there were two nuns.
Okay. I got exempted from taking Latin in high school because I had had so much Latin in the private school, albeit religious Latin, but a lot of Latin.
My publisher of the first book, what Martin say, Harper Collins. One of the editors said to me, and aside from the organization of the story in which we're going to say, Mr. Jones, we noticed that, you know, the hardly any eras, any, any grammatical eras, you know, I mean, I mean, there's some writers, you know,
writers of big names and so forth. And so we were amazed. And so I said to them, I said, well, let me, let me tell you, you should not be surprised because I think that it is still today.
It is congenital, impossible for me to write a grammatically incorrect sentence in the English language. And the reason that is so is because I learned grammar by diagram sentences, which in and of itself was not so special.
But I learned to do it correctly because when I did it incorrectly, there would be a pointer that would hit my knuckles. And I would say, you know better than that, Mr. Jones.
So I made it two years old. And I can still, I can still over all those years feel that sense of correction. But, but...
There's always a none right over it. Always a number gave me a sense of writing correctly. And then I had a great sense for the words.
So...
We're back. Great. And I will say, because this is digital recording that we're doing, we'll pause every once in a while just to save the files.
Okay, fine. Okay, very good. I'll do that.
So, you have some back to talking about this upbringing. And I wanted to ask you that, you know, this was a school for colored boys, right? But it was, I mean, you had the nuns there. It was sort of a multiracial world that you were expecting.
Well, not so much... Well, not only... Not... Well, multiracial to the extent that the nuns were white, not... But the other students, they're all colored boys and Native Americans.
I... Later on, we'll get a chance to talk about my later life with Martin Luther King, Jr.
And I don't want to go there now, but I do want to use this as an example. One day, Dr. King made a comment to me, something like, you know, Clarence, you really can get very angry.
At racism or racial injustice. And you really are angry, but you know, you're not anti-white today. And what do you... What do you count? Have you been that angry? How do you account for that? And I said, well, I think it's because as a young Negro boy growing up,
spending more time quantitatively with Irish nuns than I spent quantitatively with my parents at a critical point in my life.
Let's just break that down. The dumb and interaction of love and affection and discipline I had was from white, older women.
And they made it very clear to me and to others when they were disciplining us, or whether I had hurt myself when I was crying,
and they would hold me, they would comfort me, they would discipline me, but they did it with unconditional love.
So, you know, I'm not qualified to be a psychiatrist or I'm just looking at this young boy, that that's got to have had some impact.
If doing those formative years, you, my result is a positive, my result is a good, nothing but love and affection from these white adult women. That's what I got.
I didn't get hate, I got love and affection. I got love and affection from my parents when I saw them. But they were my serringant parents for a period of time.
So, that's a long way of saying, I said, Martin, Dr. King, I think that's the reason. I can clinically intellectually see racism for what it is.
But it's the ideology of white supremacy. It's not the white person I hate, but I dislike. So, I just a little bit of digression.
So, you know, so then I went, but had I not gone there. So, the consequence of going there was I got a better education, right?
So, when I went to public high school, as I said, I was exempted from having taken any Latin, but went to public high school. I did very well.
I was a president, I began the President of the Honest Society, at virtually all A's.
The school was Palmyra High School, Palmyra, New Jersey, Palmyra High School, Palmyra, New Jersey in Burlington County. I think my class maybe of a class of about 100, 200, maybe a class of 150, 60.
Maybe I would say 40% of the class were colored boys and girls. This is now, this is now 1945, the 1949.
Okay, high school, 1945, 1949. My classmates, 60% of more of whom were white, voted me as the most likely to succeed.
Okay? The boy in the class was likely to succeed, and they voted some young white girl classmate of mine, whose name I can't remember now, but I was voted most likely to succeed.
And was asked to be the class speaker on behalf of the Honest Society, speaking for my class.
I am in my junior year in high school, near the end of my junior year, beginning my senior year.
I went down to the Navy, and I tried to enlist. The Navy had something called a V12 program at that time.
If you enlisted in the V-12 program, you enlisted, you went into the Navy for four or six years, but the thing is they sent you to college for four years.
I think it was six years. And so I did that. Problem is you had to be 18. So I went down and, quote, enlisted in sign before I was 18.
And so I get called into the principal's office one day, and so we just got a call from a Naval Recruiting Station that said, you went down and enlisted.
Why did you lie about your age? Well, this song, so I said, I did it because I want to be able to go to college. And they said, who says you're not going to go to college?
I said, well, there's no way I can go to college. They said, we're going to go to college, we're very proud of you.
The bottom line is the principal, my speech teacher, and my science teacher. They all took money out of their own pockets in order to pay for the application fees for me to apply to college.
And so I applied to Syracuse University of Pennsylvania.
Yale and Columbia College, Columbia University. I got into all of them.
Syracuse because I had been a musician, often, me a four-year music, band scholarship, music scholarship.
What did you play? Clarenette. Clarenette. I was a professional musician when I was 16, half 17 years old.
While I was in school during the summers, I came to New York during the summers and I went to the jewelry art school in music.
I had become a fairly good instrumentalist in any event. So I lost my train of thought.
Oh, yeah, you got guns. Sit Syracuse over me, right? Sorry. Syracuse over me.
And I didn't know anything about Syracuse. Somebody said, well, you know, sorry, I called. We called up there. Plus my mother's brother.
She had a brother, my uncle, who whom I am named, Clarence. He lived in New York. And so he was an influence in my getting into Columbia College, Columbia University.
In order for me to go, I had to get a financial aid package of scholarship. In order to get a financial aid package of scholarship, I had to maintain a B-mine of Savage, which was not easy to do.
And in fact, I say to my friends out here in Silicon Valley who were interested in computer science and physics. And I said, I thought I was going to meet my academic wardeloo because I had two Nobel scientists for teachers.
One was Linus Pauling for chemistry. I did reasonably well in chemistry. But the other person was a man by the name of Polykarp Kusch. Polykarp Kusch got the Nobel Prize for physics.
And I've never knew up until that time what it was to go to class every day in sheer fear. I never was afraid. I was afraid of one of his fears. I'd be called on and I didn't understand what it was very difficult.
And I never got a course of it. And two, I think that I couldn't, I had to get a C-plus. I couldn't, I couldn't fail this course because of a jeopardized B-mine of Savage. I got a C-plus in physics. That's the only C-plus I got.
I got the rest of the B-minuses in A-s and so on. But it was my wardeloo.
So my teachers helped me do this.
Did you maintain contact with your parents?
I'm going to say yes when I... I don't know what the economy was, but I'm trying to remember...
I think that Mrs. Lippincott died at some point.
And my father stayed on as a caretaker of the place. But my mother took a job in Westchester County, New York, and she would come back home about twice a month.
But when I was in Columbia, she would be in New York on her days off. I would be able to see her, one of the more touching things I remember.
I was always working, I worked at the dining hall tables for food and then extra money.
There used to be a chain similar to Starbucks. Only Starbucks would probably be offended if I could say the chain was called Nidix.
There was a Nidix hotdog. If anybody talks about Nidix, it's like Nathan's Frankfurt. You date yourself. You date yourself and tell you what part of the country you grew up in.
So I worked at a Nidix on 42nd Street in Leckington Avenue. One day I worked at my home. I look up and there's my mother sitting at the counter.
She came down to see me and so forth and worked. Very...
I was moving. Now I'm going to tell you something that probably...
I would say that it's the education I got at, the Catholic boarding school, Cornwells Heights, it was called, in eastern...
Cornwell's Pennsylvania. It was in eastern EAST, ERN, geographically, Pennsylvania.
I would say being at that school and then going to Columbia, and even before I got to Columbia,
being an accomplished... becoming an accomplished clarinetist, you know, filled in gave me some sense of confidence, you know,
because I was the first clarinetist in our... in the orchestra and first clarinetist in the band, and then the singular achievement at that time they had the...
the state of New Jersey hit, a New Jersey All-State orchestra, which you auditioned for. And in my senior year I was the first clarinetist for the, you know, for a room.
Now there's some funny, there's some humorous little side stories. I learned to play jazz and it was a theater in New York called the The Earle Theatre.
That was like the Apollo Theater in New York. And the The Earle Theatre used to have amateur hour. And, you know, what happens?
You go in for one ticket, you see a movie and you see a live stage show. And then they turned the lights out because they have to turn out.
They want to get a hold on you couldn't... you couldn't sit through for a whole nother show, you know.
And once a week they had what in effect was an amateur hour.
So, you know, I would come very good. I was a very good classical clarinetist and was moving pretty good to become a little jazz.
So I'm on this amateur hour competition. And as a white guy there, an Italian guy from Philadelphia, he was unbelievable on the clarinet.
I mean, he was just unbelievable. About a year and a half older than me. His name was Buddy DeFranco.
I mean, when I heard him play as I said, I mean, I was good. Now Buddy DeFranco and I became friends thereafter.
I mean, he was one of the great, he maybe still lived me. He's one of the great clarinetists of our time.
Alright, but he was great. So, now, during that period of time, I went to Juilliard School of Music twice during those summers.
The betraying is a classical clarinetist. There's a place at that time in New York called, it was called Manny's Music on 48th Street.
48th of 46th, I think it was 48th Street. But Manny's had a tradition. I think it was on Wednesday or Thursday. I mean, it may have been Thursday, late afternoon.
They had a tradition of having musicians. It was a music store. It sold musical instruments principally at the principal.
At that time, the instruments were trumpets, saxophone, clarinet, trombones, and so forth. It wasn't like... They had guitars,
but it wasn't like flutterwood guns, dominant things, where the reeds, the trumpets, the trombones, the clarinet, some saxophones.
And I used to go and have my clarinet service there, you know, when I was there. And I got to know many the only.
It took to me like, it's just something he... He just liked me as a young, you know, the Negro clarinetist.
I think he also liked the fact that I was a classical clarinetist trained. And I, and so... And I learned a little bit jazz. He says, well, one day, he says, you know, he says, you know, Charlie Parker Charlie Barker's here.
He's playing upstairs. I told Charlie Parker about you. I said, yeah, what would you tell him? I said, you know, you're very talented and so forth.
He's there upstairs playing now. Why don't you go up? I said, no, I said, yeah, I'd like to go up so forth, you know.
And so my clarinet was being fixed and so forth and so forth. So I go up and I'm listening and I'm very shy. And then many comes up having done what he had done to my clarinet.
He had put it together in the box and so forth and so forth. And so Charlie Parker says to me, yeah, he told me, he says, you got your axe? And I said, yeah, he says, well, just said, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I can't do that. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, you put that thing together, boy. Put that thing together. And I'm shaking.
I'm shaking.
And he's playing and so forth. He says, well, what are you? What's your favorite? And I just said, well, you know, I can't. I said, I said, Mr. Parker, don't call me Parker. Call me Charlie Parker.
I said, I said, you know, you just play along and I'll just sit and so forth. And then, and then as I got into it, I said, well, do you know, way back home in Indiana?
He said, yeah, I know. I'm in the end of a case. So forth. So, and he played way back home and then sunny side in the street and so forth.
And I was sitting there, it sort of, you know, uncomfortably getting his custom. And then when he switched and played way back home in Indiana, which was the fastest of tempo, sunny side in the street.
They're playing and playing and I'm playing along with him. And he's looking at me and he goes to me like that. And I said, oh, my God.
Well, I'm frozen there. The best I could do was improvise. Okay.
The only thing is like, this is like an author boy being an author boy for the Pope. You know, you know, do that.
But I, but it gave me, I did what I had to do, you know, and then of course, like any, like any comforting, caring, elder, you know.
He said, you're on your way, boy, you're on your way, you're on your way, you're on your way. I mean, you know, it was encouraging me.
The man was an unbelievable genius. We could have an interview just about Charlie Parker, but I want to, I want to say this about Charlie Parker.
Those people who may not be musicians who will see this, you have to understand what Charlie Parker could do is that there would be a melodic line.
And Charlie Parker had the capacity of improvising within the melodic line. He would improvise so that you could hear the line, but the improvisation would be so extraordinary.
The classic example is April and Paris. Okay. You listen to that's what he did. You know, I mean, to bring it.
So, so that had a profound, that had a profound effect on me. But when I was in college, I had to make a, I had to make a decision. I couldn't, I couldn't practice a little.
So, in the great pressure to do well, I played the sports because I just, it was in my system. But the most profound event that occurred in my life occurred during when I was in college,
shaped me to be very much who I am today. And that event was this. It was the beginning of my junior year. It was in January. I was taking midterm examinations.
And while I'm taking midterm examinations, the proctor comes in and says, are you Clarence Jones? And I said, yes, I am. He said, well, there is an emergency call for you. You need to go to the dean's office.
Now, ironically, I was taking this midterm examination on my birthday, January 8th, 1952. I go to the dean's office and I said, Mr. Jones, we got a call from the hospital in Camden, New Jersey.
Cooper's hospital, I mean, Cooper's something hospital, and I said, yes, apparently, we don't know the details, which are mothers in the hospital. You need to call this number immediately.
So, you know, I'm trying to decide. So I call, I said, essentially, my father was so broken up, he was a really difficult, he was a communicator, a doctor got on the phone and said,
we, your mother, we just operate on your mother. And we had to ask your father's consent. They had to take her a bowel track out, do a coloscopy in a bag, because she has cancer in her rectum.
A abdominal rectal cancer, and she probably has about three or four months to live. I mean, I'm, so I, I go back and I say to the proctor, it was an S, I said,
I, I want to try to see if I can send 15 minutes to try to finish where I am in the exam. So I finished and it in my paper.
And I went to, got on the bus, or go to the hospital. And it was, it was just, all this was a shock to me. My father was just in, in, in, in, in, consultable grief.
So, we bring my mother home, in the hospital. When I talk to the doctor, and I'm talking to my mother. And she is very upset that I am there.
That she, she was started to cry, why are you here? You should be in school. I said, well, my mother, her and so forth. She said, no, no, no, no, mom is going to be alright. You've got to go back to school. So I mean, I talked to the doctor.
And, and he says, well, Mr. Jones, this is what it is. You know, I went in to see the dean of college.
And my attitude was, you know, I can always get an education.
This is, this is, this is my mother, you know. So I wanted to, I wanted to take a leave of absence. I wanted to drop out, take a leave of absence. He says, no, I don't think you need to do that clearance.
Why don't we work out something where you just, you just stay. And we'll work out something with your classes, you know, you try to keep up.
And I had some friends and so, so what I did was that I, I stayed in school. But I set up, I put a, I put a desk at the foot of my mother's bed in her bedroom. And I swear I did all my homework.
And I had to leave periodically to go back to New York. I also had to leave to keep some credibility with her because she refused to believe that in fact I had permission to study. She just refused to believe that she would cry.
You know, Mama, what you're going to have an education is an education. Okay.
May 4th, 1952 she dies. She's buried on May 8th.
When they, she was 160 pounds about, tall, five foot, 10, 155, 60 pounds.
She died. She was about 99 pounds, less than 99 pounds. They took her body out from the mattress and took her to the undertaker place.
And when they removed her body and they were removing the bed things, you know, I saw that there was a letter under the mattress that she had written to me.
All during the time she was six, she was carrying on this charade. And Mama's going to get better. Mama's going to get better. You know, she's going to be, not going to be as different.
I'm going to have to get adjusted to doing things. But Mama's going to get better. We're going to get better. She was losing more weight anyway.
So she leaves this letter to me. And the essence of the letter is that she's apologizing to me. She's asking, my forgiveness for leaving me.
She's asking, my forgiveness. And she's talking about how proud I have made her feel that no mother, she says, could ask for a son that could bring her great joy.
And then my favorite, she was a cook, one of the best cooks in the world. And she, I was a dessert, you know, how I'm so to speak. And so she knew that the things that she homemade for me were crullers and a dessert called floating island.
And she says, she says, I'm Mama's sorry she can't be here to make crullers and floating island. But I wrote the recipe down for you. And I'm sorry to leave you, but you know, I know that someday you're going to be a great man.
I know you're going to be a great man and always try to be good and always try to make me proud because I know I am so proud of you. And someday you're going to be a great man.
I'm sorry I have to leave you. Please forgive me.
Okay. Well, let me tell you something. I was an only child, I know your brother's sister.
I spent a limited amount of time with my parents. But as I begin going forward in my life and I measured things in terms of how difficult they were or how painful they were.
It became very clear that my internal gyroscope was founded on the following.
I had been to the apex and the mountaintop of pain. I couldn't conceive of anything happening in my life thereafter.
I couldn't conceive of anything thereafter, having a more profound effect of loss in anguish and the loss of my mother.
So, when I would study and read the political history of China, and I would see that Chou and Lai, when a great China's political leader says the strongest steel, is tempered by the hottest fire.
I knew what he was saying. It also conditioned me to have the dialectic of compassion and strength.
Okay. So, that for example, the Korean War broke out in June 25th, 1950. I was a student.
As a student, I was entitled to a student deferment.
Because in the aftermath of my mother's death, in 52, I was scheduled to graduate in 53, because in order to sustain, maintain your exemption, your student deferment, either had to graduate or you had to be full-time in school.
And if you were a nearing graduation, you had to have made an application to a graduate school.
Okay. And if you didn't have either of those things, you were not entitled to exempt me, exempt from the job.
So, my job board snatched me, because I was in the space. I was drafted in August 12th, 1953.
I was angry. I had also become politicized in college.
I had also met in New York to my uncle, an extraordinary man, who I didn't even know who he was.
I heard you, I saw him and went to see him in a Broadway play, but then I found that he was an actor with Paul Robeson.
I went to see him in Othello or on Whitman Avenue or something. I went to see him in something with Uta Hagen on Broadway.
And my uncle had become friends with him. And when I was in Columbia, I had two instances with Paul Robson.
I had been active politically in college. This is before my mother died in 1952, but that whole area between 1949 and 1952 had been active and so forth.
And I loved football in addition to all the other things. But if you loved football, you either played football in Baker's Field as a part of the Columbia team,
or if you went to a football game, and I was not varsity, but I was in line with the varsity team.
So I would go to every football team, every Saturday, I'd be up at Baker's Field at Columbia, New York.
And my classmates who were more politically inclined would say, well, you know, when we have to hand out leaflets, you never hand out any leaflets, you're never there.
You're never there, you know, you need a committee and I commit it. So I told Paul Robeson this story once I was so I'm socially with my uncle Leda, party, and I told him that story.
He was tall and big, and he says, you know, you go back and you tell your white, liberal progressive friends, I have lots of white progressive friends,
but you go back and tell your white progressive friends who are students, that one touchdown on a Saturday afternoon by you, a Negro in Baker's Field with that stadium filled with almost 50,000 people.
One touchdown have greater impact on getting white people to understand the equality of Negroes than anything they could ever write in those leaflets.
And I was like, this is for us, never would we get that. The other instance that influenced on me is that he at this time was being summoned before the House of American Activities Committee.
And I watched him on television.
So let me just, let me just, you go back and look at the archives, I would suggest you go back and look at Paul Robeson appearing before the House Internal Security Committee, the House on American Communities Committee, but it was chaired by James Eastland from Mississippi.
And when Paul Robeson was being asked, the sit is sworn in as a witness by the chairman, he stands up for six foot, four or six foot, he says, you, he points his finger at him.
You Mr. Wieslin, you are unconstitutionally seated in that chair. You don't have the authority, the constitutional hourly authority to ask me any questions whatsoever because you were illegally sitting in this Congress.
You were illegally because of the mass exclusion of my people invoting. You have no authority whatsoever to ask me any questions. I said, wow, that was a bad dude.
Okay, I mean it influenced me, okay. So my mother dies, influenced Paul Robeson, my anger, not getting exempted. So when I report the night before the induction, by the way, I had some left wing.
I'm not going to say they were communist because I don't know that they were communist. It was the young, young friends of mine, but they were members of the Labor Youth League, which was supposed to have been a communist-affiliated organization, but they were left, but they were very, they were just great friends of mine.
I had a...
What was the effect of inter-refuge for a second when you were talking about your friends that were illegal being it? Is this the same group or is this the same kind of politics there?
No, no, no, these were different. There were friends, they were an extended group. They weren't necessarily, the Paul Robeson comments were meant to my friends who, yes, I said, no matter if they were the same. They were substantially the same.
But I had become friends with... And one woman by the name of Judith Treesman, Judy, I don't know whether you're alive, whether you have a...
Here, this is a seedest, but I had such admiration for her and her family treated me like I was just part of their family, great warmth.
And I remember Judy Treisman, I mean, that was where she was at the young woman at that time. I don't know where it is today, but at that time she says, you know,
you know, you know, you don't want to go. If you don't want to report, you know, maybe you just think about it.
If you want to go to Canada or if you don't want to go to Canada, I think you should go to Eastern Europe, Czechoslovakia and so forth like that.
No, no, no, no, and then she says, well, you know, she said, don't get the wrong idea. You know, I parents like you and I like you.
And I mean, I really care about you. So all I'm simply saying, if you wanted to go and I said, I'd go with you, if I would make it easy for you.
You know, and I find something to do. And I said, what are you talking about? She says, yeah, I would do that.
You know, because I know you're hurting. I know you don't want to go. And I said, no, Judy, I can't do that. But I seriously thought about it.
I seriously thought about it. But as a result of the anger of being inductive and I didn't think I should have been inducted,
in my draft board in Mount Holly, New Jersey, I signed from Richard Vilariani, who was a news, who went to Burlington, high school in Burlington, New Jersey.
There were very few college students. And I still did this day believe that this this this prejudice in Manholy draft board saying, well, we'll send this Negro, you know, draft them, who's they think he is.
I mean, I think if I think I had been white, I wouldn't think I'd have been drafted. I think I just said, oh, he's a role to Columbia College.
And yes, he had a problem with this. I don't think that a draft of me has mother died. No, they didn't. They didn't care. So I was bitter.
So the night before I was to report for induction, I sat down and wrote a handwritten note as to why I was reporting for induction, but why I was not going to serve in the Army.
And I in the course of the note, I said, in effect, I said, I'm willing to go and serve and and and give my life for my country as a member of the United States Army.
When my country cheese me as a first class citizen, I'm not willing to put my life on the line in a war that I have lots of questions about the Korean War, lots of questions, but I'm not willing to do that.
And so therefore I'm reporting for induction and I cited the first. I wasn't a lawyer. I don't know anything. I mean, I was educated or being excited the first, the fifth, the 14th and 15th of members of the Constitution.
As a reason I was not. So I'm in Whitehall Street, New York. I report for duty August 13th early in the morning. Now, have you seen some of these military pictures? When you report to duty, the first thing the non-commissioned officer says, and it was a Negro, non-commissioned officer, he says, all right, Cece, okay.
You raise your hand, you know, you're being inducted to the Army. Well, I didn't raise my hand, you know, because I figured if I didn't, if I didn't consent to this, they couldn't, so I didn't raise my hand.
So I'm listening to all this ramp about, you know, your ass is grass now, you know, you're in the Army, you belong to us.
And then Sergeant, he says, well, what's with you? What's with you soldier? And I said, there's nothing, I just, I said, I'm here when reporting.
What are you some kind of cook or conscientious objective? And I said, no. And then I gave him a statement to read. And he read it, he said, what are you some kind of commie? I said, no. He said, well, get out of line.
So he puts me out of line. And then they, they, a captain, a white captain officer comes over and so what's the problem?
Private Jones, what's the problem with Mr. Jones, he said. I said, well, I realize I'm here because I want to show up. But I don't, these are my reasons why I don't want to serve sir.
I don't think I think I'm being unfairly treated and I want to serve you, read it. And that's when he says, oh, he said, we better come over here.
And they had some kind of conference for about two or three, but two hours. Whatever they decided, oh, yeah, whatever they decided you go, they were going to put me on the bus to Fort Dix.
So I go to Fort Dix. And somebody at Fort Dix had been alerted that I was on the bus and coming. Now, in the Fort Dix, that's when they, that's when it gets serious.
Because that's when they want you to sign up for your, your insurance, you sign, you're going to get paid, the issue your clothes, you know, you, you, and so they kept saying, you know, you know, sign this, you know, you're not going to get any money.
I said, I don't care. I'm not signing anything. What? Well, if you can't sign, you're not going to have any insurance. You're not going to, you're not going to get any paycheck. You're not going to get anything. I said, I don't care. I'm not signing anything.
So they issue me, they issue me standard things, they put me and they process me to go for basic training. But no, stop there. Before they process me, I take, I take examinations, okay, placement examination.
Don't do so. So about three or four days after I take the placement examination, I find that they're putting me in a group that scheduled to go to some place in Maryland.
Because we're going to be part of some special forces team, so special forces intelligence team. So I said, I think there must be some mistake.
So I remember going to one of these two orientation things. I'm listening. And I'm talking about how they're going to, we're going to be trained as going to the special unit. Some of us may go to California to the Army language school to learn Russian or Polish, principally that.
I'm thinking to myself and then I put it all together. Because I talked to some of the other soldiers who were all gone ho about this. They're going to send you to Fort Jackson to Parachupir School and so forth.
The bottom line is that they were being trained to be special ops who would jump at night behind me in lines in a Soviet Union and pull on the Czechoslovakia. So I said, so I'm laughing while I find out I said, now, this is after they go to the Army language school.
So I said, now, now let's assume that I go through all this and I'm fluent in Russian. How am I going to explain this black face of mine as I show up in the Russian countryside, the Polish countryside? I said, this is crazy. It's crazy.
I mean, that's on saying the military was at the point. But anyway, so I, I, I mean, the whole of it and I was bitter, angry over the death of my mother and really, and really, I really began to, I was influenced by Paul Rupsen and I figured I, you know, and, and I also trying to find a way of getting out. I'm not doing it.
I just wanted to ask, this is a good time, I think, to ask, what other influences beyond Rupsen? I mean, with the people that you were reading, had, had looking back, you know, this is a very device. What do you think inspired us?
I think my friends, I had become, I had become, I become friends with a lot of New York student leftists who had become, in one case, a couple of cases had become very dear friends of mine.
In one case, I can think of as a poet by the name of Robert Barron Nemiroff. Robert Nemiroff was getting a master's degree in English from NYU. We became, he even got a Columbia, he went to NYU.
And we became friendly through our, my political activities in New York. And Robert's family owned a restaurant, an Israeli restaurant, on 48, 46th street in Manhattan called the Habibi Restaurant.
And it was, it was a nightclub, Mr. Ron. And, and Robert introduced me to his parents, particularly his mother. And when his mother found out that I was at Columbia, that I was working on tables and she, and I was skinny. And she says, well, speaking in Newtish, she spoke very little English.
And, and so Bobby would be talking to her and Yiddish and talking to me in English. Which by the way, as a result of that relationship, three or four or five years of knowing her, I was fairly
capable and conversational Yiddish. Particularly when it came to food, you know, I used to, people, I would say, people say, well, how do you know anything about Canadian lock? I said, I know Canadian lock a multiple, I know it because I used to have it all the time.
And, and anyway, they had this, this nightclub. And, and she would have me come down and eat outside the kitchen, right to the entrance of the kitchen to the nightclub where they would have the restaurant part. I would come anytime. And then I wouldn't do it except maybe on the weekends.
Weekends, I'd come there, weekends before. But anyway, I became very, very close to Robert B. Nemiroff, he and I became friends. And he ended up marrying Lorraine Hansberry, the playwright, who also became a friend of mine when I was in school.
Lorraine Hansberry was an African American playwright from Chicago, became good friends of mine. She married Robert B. Nemiroff. And the other good friend of mine were the Art D'Lugoff + Burt D'Lugoff brothers.
Art D'Lugoff was an entrepreneur and owned the village gate, nightclub, and his brother, Bert, owned the nightclub with him except Bert went to medical school to John Hopkins.
So, while, while Art was running the nightclub, Bert was in medical school to John Hopkins. But those were, those were my good friends.
And then, you know, I go through the military experience.
I've become friendly. But first of all, there are a couple of people in the military that when they found out these all, oh, this is 19, I mean in military in 1953, it's a 55, okay.
The military only be segregated beginning in 1950, okay. The executive order late 1940 number, Harry Truman. So only had an integrated army for three years.
So I was in company D, 47th Regiment, in Fort Dix. And I just remembered being about, I don't know.
Maybe it was, maybe it was 40% black, maybe it was about 40% black or more.
So, I had a company commander who was from Mississippi, Captain, and non-commissioned offices were virtually all Negro at that time.
So, I'm in the military and I become very, very close friends.
One, one word spreads that I'm going to be here indefinitely or more specifically, I am not going to be shipped overseas after basic training.
Guys came coming up the men said, well, tell me how you did this. Because they wanted to revoke. They didn't, they wanted to be in a holdover status. They didn't want to be shipped out.
And the only way you could get a discharge in the army is a dishonable discharge, a section 8 being crazy or an undesirable. So all of them wanted to be a section 8 crazy.
I had a good friend of mine who says, oh, I'm a communist. I said, well, this name was fields. I said, I'm not a communist. Well, no, but then they won't say, I'm going to go back and told them, I mean, I didn't even look at that thing. I signed that law of the youth.
I didn't sign the law of the youth. I didn't make that clear to you. When I handed my statement, I also, as part of the various series of papers you signed consenting to being in the army, there's a whole lot of papers but attaches those papers where a list was a lawyer for 400 organizations that the then attorney general, a graph of Herbert Brownell determined was on either communist or communist front organizations.
Including a lot of, I mean, organizations, I knew in that communist. The young progressives of America, they were not a communist organization, but they were there.
And so I didn't sign it.
So word spread that I had not signed it. And so some of the soldiers are saying, we don't know whether, you know, what you are not. And in the other word, spread.
And so it's like being in the military is a little bit like prison, you know. Words spread that I had to somebody said to be careful because the words said to somebody, I needed to be taken into a shower and taught a lesson in loyalty.
So you better watch yourself.
And when I developed a very good friendship with a guy, was a big guy like a football player. He became very close friends. He was somewhat protective of me too.
His last name was Hinton. Big guy. Very good friends. Fast forward.
I'm sitting in a bar somewhere in Harlem on leave, talking to Clint. We're drinking, trying to see what girls are going to get so far.
And he starts to cry. So I think it's too much liquor. You know, you know, we started crying. You know, it had a lot of, a lot to drink, a lot of beers. So I had to cry.
And then he told me, he said, I had treated him like a brother. I had taken him to my family and he is, he is so sorry. I said, what are you sorry about? He says, you know, my main job here in this, in your platoon is to report about you.
I said, what do you mean you've put about me? He said, I have to write reports about you. I said, what kind of reports? Well, you know, whether you've ever said anything against the United States, whether, whether you're a communist.
And I said, well, the only thing he likes is sports and girls. You know, sports and women, that's all he talks about.
And you've introduced me to some of your good friends and so forth. And he had a lot to drink. And he just unburdened. And I said, I can't.
So that was over a weekend, right?
I go back, we go back to camp on the fourth of formation on Monday. Monday afternoon and Monday evening, I'm looking for a hit and he's gone.
I never saw him again. I never saw him again. I'm in the army for 21 months.
And where did he serve the war? Fort Dex. That's Fort Dex for 24 months.
I was trained into telecommunications, army, signal communications, teaching the media intricacies of how to operate signal equipment on the field and so forth.
So I went to the whole basic training. I went through everything and you go, Divwack, you know, marches for 26 par. I did the whole thing.
But 21 months, I'm in my barracks one morning, getting ready to go to what I normally do.
And an MP comes in, two MPs come in. And one MP says, are you private Jones? They yes. They had me this paper.
And it's a, they had me this paper and in a sense it's like a summons and complaint.
It's a notice that they're bringing me up for court marshaling me as a security risk with this whole series of allegations.
So one allegation being that I had refused to sign the loyalty of the other allegation being that since 1938 up until the present I'm a member of the Communist Party.
Well, of course I was only seven years old in 1938.
The other was that I had lived, which is true. After, after my mother died, my last year in college, and one I had lived in a housing development.
One by the I.O. International labor union, one of the labor unions that was deemed to be a communist front-leab you that I lived there. That's where I lived.
And the other was that I had maintained a very close friend, which was true.
And the doctor who was still today, he's retired or doctorate at the Stanford University, who at the time had been a vice president of the International Union of Students.
Been a member of the Communist Party since I was eight. Didn't sign a loyalty of, lived in the Allerton Avenue houses and the Bronx.
And so I'm assigned a council, the Bence Council, and they have this steel board of inquiry at Fort Dix.
And my commanding officer is called. And so I'm the principal evidence they put in, or the allegations.
And we both the allegations, they said, well, not a member of the Communist Party. Yes, it is true. He did live there. Yes, it is true. He knows so and so. Yes, it is true.
He didn't sign the loyalty of, and even my, Judge Advocate General lawyer said, well, these are all, you're, you're, you're.
He put my commanding officer on the stand. They said to testify to whether I was a good soldier.
Bottom line, if you could have clearance zone in your company, he said, he was the number one soldier of the honor to have him serve an anytime, never heard him, nothing could get glowing remarks.
Plus, I had been chosen as soldier of the month. And soldier of the month, let me tell you, I get, I become soldier of the month.
I become soldier of the month for the 47th regiment, something for tie in the way soldier of the month is that you, you stand before your footlocker and your need is closed and your footlocker is in perfect shape and your bed is made so they put a quarter or something and it's so for you.
Shoes are shine. And then you're asked to take your disassemble your M-1 rifle. Okay. And reassemble that. Blindfold it. Okay.
I did that and got a perfect score. And so as a result of that, I was given the good conduct metal. So I was, I was chosen as soldier of the month, given a good conduct metal and a special three day leave and all this is in the record when I'm being courtmorshaw.
The verdict comes down the very next day. I've been found the undesirable national security was to the United States government and to the United States military.
At which point two M poos came took me back to my barracks. They supervised me packing up all of my things, put me in a duffle bag, put me in a jeep with a one way ticket to Port Authority.
And they waited until the bus they put me on it. They escorted me to the exits, the gate of fort fort dicks under arm guard and put me on the bus under arm guard.
I was given an undesirable discharge on August 13th, 1955. I think it was August 14th. I think I was inducted on August 13th, but I was returned on August 14th.
So as I'm riding in on the bus, I'm smouldering and I'm thinking they don't know what they got their hands.
So I go and I'm staying with my uncle. I discuss it with my uncle. My uncle says, well I think you got to go see the American Civil Liberties Union.
So I go down to the American Civil Liberties Union. I tell them my story and they have me meet with a lawyer by the name of Stanley Faulkner, God rest his soul.
Stanley Faulkner, we filed an appeal. It was the first time I went, the first time I went into the Pentagon.
The Pentagon has something called the Army Discharge Review Board. The Army Discharge Review Board, the Armed Services Discharge Review Board.
It's consistent like the Supreme Court, all of the uniformed services are sitting in bunk, you know, the Navy, the Marines, the Coast Guard, the Air Force are all sitting there. Military officers.
And it's like the Court of Appeals. Excuse me, I need to go to the men's room. Take a break.
So I said, I said, so I went to Stanley Faulkner and it's like an appeal. And, and he subpoenaed and my military commander and everything was there to make a long story short as a result of the appeal.
They handed me, they awarded me a general discharge. They moved up my discharge one notch. Stanley Faulkner says, no, that's not satisfactory. He's entitled to an unrupl discharge.
And I, and I hadn't, I wasn't thinking about what I was, what I was going to do, but I decided I wanted to go to law school at that time.
And I, I considered, I went to Columbia College and I was considering about making, I went and went up to talk to Columbia Law School and I told them the problem I had.
They didn't even get to the question whether, and grades and applications and so forth. They discouraged me because they said that, why you have this problem, I think you ought to get this problem solved before you consider me enter law school, you don't know.
You know, you're not going to be able to be a lawyer if you'd have this thing hanging over you.
Meanwhile, I had become friendly with the judge, he would delay me and some other lawyers and they suggested I go and talk to Boston University Law School.
So I talked to Boston University Law School and I told them the issue and they said, well, listen, if you want a legal education, you can just, you know, you will give your legal education.
You will decide whether you're going to ever practice, but you will admit you, you know, you get your papers.
The mere fact that this is, that you have currently an undesirable discharge has been general and you don't know how it's going to appeal, that's not going to stop you.
So you're welcome to come.
I keep thinking, of course, I need an honorable discharge because as an honorable discharge, I'd qualify for the Korean Conflict GI Bill.
Okay? So Stanley Faulkner, we sued, he brought a rid of mandamus, I believe.
A rid of mandamus for those people who met for me, it's a, it's an administrative proceeding that's brought against an officer of the government agency.
To compel that person, to perform the duties that he is, or she is required to do according to the statute.
So Stanley Faulkner's thesis was that the Secretary of the Army, he had a constitutional, he was compelled by the nature of the party to issue me an honorable discharge.
Okay? I'm at Boston University Law School.
I'm registering, knowing full well, but maybe I'll win the case and maybe I won't win the case, but Boston, they're already working out a situation where if I could come up with just a modest little amount for the down payment, they'll carry me and so forth, and they're working at the best of region they could.
I haven't completed registering in law school, hadn't gotten my books.
When I got this urgent message to call Stanley Faulkner, I call Stanley Faulkner, and he said, we won, you've just been issued an honorable discharge.
And this is what you must tell me. You must, I'm going to get in touch with the Veterans Administration Officer in Boston and tell them that we're going to have your copy of your order, so forth, so that you can get your benefits.
That's what happened. Is that the Veterans Administration was notified, I had an honorable discharge, the VA then notified the Berzer at Boston University,
and they then activated me as being going to school and getting my tuition in the Korean Conflict GI Bill, and low in behold.
I got a check for, I don't know, several thousand dollars, maybe about 12 thousand, maybe I don't know, 13 thousand or something, for all the back pay, all the back pay which I didn't get military.
I didn't get any pay, paycheck, that will time.
But I introduced this by talking about the death of my mother, because her death made me fearless.
I didn't have any brothers and sisters, I didn't have any brothers and sisters to comfort me.
Okay?
I became very clear to me that we are all, to a large extent, the challenges to what extent can you control your own destiny and not have it determined by a third party.
And what are you prepared to put at risk? What are you prepared?
Now, my attitude, I lost my mother, I didn't feel like I could lose anything. I wasn't afraid of anything.
I was angry. And during the period, I go to the New York Public Library the day after I get into New York, and I'm saying at my uncle's place and he's telling me to go down.
I go to the New York Public Library because I was trying to decide what I'm going to do and go into the library, be paper and stuff.
And I hear somebody call my name. I don't know if it's a call my name.
Clarence Jones is not you, Clarence Jones, I turn around. And as a woman, and I had seen this woman in like five years.
And she was Ann Norton. Ann Norton had gone to Sarah Lawrence. And when I was at Columbia, occasionally a group of guys from Columbia would go up and party at Sarah Lawrence.
And Sarah Lawrence, at that time, the women lived in houses, different houses. So it was a big thing to be able to go on a Saturday night to go to Sarah Lawrence because that's where you had all these girls.
And Norton was, they had parties and I knew her. She was white. And I knew she would, you know, she was one of those active progressive, very nice people.
And last thing I heard, she was living in Chicago, working for Spiegel's and so forth. No, no, she's in New York now working for the American National Theatre Company. What's that? What's, you know, an American National Theatre Company? What are you doing? What are you doing? What are you doing?
I was talking, and I just told, I told the story about what happened to me in the Army. She's, oh my God, well, where are you staying? I'm staying with my uncle. And she says, this is, I never will be, she says, well, what are you doing tomorrow?
I said, I don't know what I'm doing. I'm doing, what I'm doing tomorrow, she says, well, you know, the American National Theatre is having our annual thing on Broadway.
Would you like to come? You know, you've been in the Army, would you like to come? Being a good boy, I said, sure. So I go to the American National Theatre Company's production of Damn Yankees, okay?
Gwen Verden, okay? It was a second Broadway play I'd ever seen. The first had been with my uncle when I had seen Paul Roveson. Maybe it was on Whitman, I had something with you to hug. And I was the second time, okay?
But this time, I mean, I had good seats there with Paul Robeson with you to hug. But this time I'm with Antony and I get the very great seats.
And I didn't have a tuxedo. My uncle and I are about the same size. So I had to go and borrow his dark blue suit.
And I wore a bow tie, a black bow tie and a white shirt and a dark blue suit. And I wear and a pair of his dark shoes, like shoes. I never knew. That's how I went to. And to wear my uncle's clothes.
We went to Sardi's. She began with a friend of hers. This is all during the appeal process. And during the appeal process, she had to type up.
I had to provide copies of the transcripts. It was for a lot of photocopying, so forth. So she and a woman friend of hers, they spent hours typing up my appeal transcript.
And during that whole process, we became romantically involved. And then I married her. And that was a major turning point in my life.
And so my father had remarried. I married one of my mother's best friends when I came to, I mean, I liked so forth. And so I let my father and my new stepmother know I was going to get married.
And I had become friendly with a couple. Charles W. White and Fran Barrett White. Charles W. White was an artist. Very distinguished artist at UCLA at one point.
One of the before Romare Bearden and Romare Bearden and one of the great artists. He was the best man at my wedding to Ann. And Fran Barrett was, I guess, the maid of honor to Ann.
We were, we were getting very good friends. And my, my, my, my in laws, my wife's parents were reconciled. They were not, they were not unfriendly.
They were sort of matter of fact, protocol friendly, you know, but not hostile in any way. They were at the wedding. We had a reception at the Belmont Hotel, a wedding cake and all of that.
When Ann and I were dating, I learned, I mean, I knew it in general, but I didn't know the details. We got closer to it. I learned that yes, her parents had founded the WWE Northern publishing company. And Ann was in Northern, in Northern was because
William Warder Norton founded the WWE Northern publishing company with her mother. And so she came from a publishing business. And that her father had died, her father had died when she was 18 and 19. Her mother remarries.
Her mother remarries a banker, an international banker from Holland. His name is Daniel H. Crena de Iongh, C-R-E-N-E-A, small D-E, capital I-O-N-G-H.
He was the head of the banking industry in the Netherlands, the number one bank of the Netherlands. He became, he was also one of the early, not one of the first treasuries of the World Bank.
But affecting my relationship was not those, was that his very best friend in the world, whom he vacationed with and when he married Anne's mother, whom they vacationed with.
In Johannesburg, South Africa was Hendrik Verwoerd, the architect of a part-time. My stepfather in law is the banker for not only the Netherlands, but is the banker for Heinrich Fairbold and that whole nationalist party.
Now he treated me with protocol warmth and courtesy. It was something almost like out of Downton Abbey. I mean, it was like, it was like, he cheated me as a gentleman.
There was no hostility toward me. It wasn't a question whether he approved or disapproved. He accepted as a fact. I was married to his wife's daughter and he treated me with great friendship initially and then it eventually became affection and respect.
We had a kind of annual ritual. He was a member of the Netherlands Club in the somewhere near Rockefeller Center and every holiday he would take me to lunch at his Netherlands Club where other international bankers would be.
He would probably introduce me as his son-in-law and the breakthrough in the relationship with my indoors came.
When my wife's mother, who was a classical chamber music, violist, when her daughter had told me that I played the clarinet, suggested that I bring up my clarinet one weekend, not knowing what I could play.
She heard me play warm up. The best thing I can tell you was that it blew her away because I sat down when she was just watching this thing. I said, why don't I play for you? The Mozart clarinet concerto in A for you to listen to you. You just sit over there and I'll play. She was stunned.
The next week, this is in Wilton, Connecticut. The next week, she arranges for there to be a chamber music group in which her son-in-law is going to be the clarinetist in which we played Brahms, Mozart, but things for clarinet and strings and cello and flute are primarily written by Brahms and Mozart Beethoven writing some things.
And then, of course, I would perform solo pieces like Flight of the Bumblebee. That single act made my mother alone go out of her way to tell other people about how she wanted them to meet me and how he's been able to play the piano.
It was busy, but we want him to come up here every weekend because you have to see him and so forth as a person. And I write one of my books. I write one of my books when she heard me play the Mozart clarinet concerto. It was a whole. She heard me play this before we had any children because no one had children.
Now, had you and Anne talked about what life might be like for you as an interracial couple at that time, or did you have other examples of couples that you knew?
Well, Charlie White was a black artist married to a white woman, a fan baron.
And I say this, not in criticism. And went to the, and went to the The Brearley School, private girl school. She went to Sarah Lawrence and she was in high school. She was raised by a governess.
In addition to having a home in Wilton, her parents had a townhouse on Gramercy Park. And at that time, everybody who owned a townhouse had a key to the park.
So I remember we lived in the head of the townhouse with 17 Gramercy Park. And Anne had a tremendous deep idealism, but also had a certain kind of
sort of nutritionist, certain kind of attitude that she was certain she was right. The classic example, this is after we're living in Boston.
My oldest daughter, the baby, was shopping at a food place and a check out. And Anne had to go back. So Tina Christine was in this little bassinet and we left her right up on the counter, you know, on the other checkout counter.
And I was standing there by, and the checkout counter, I must have returned and somebody said, well, whose little baby is this? You know, not in a negative way. But my wife saw this. And like a lioness, you know, this is what I'm going to say.
And her way of dealing with this. So she's, she's white, fair skin, blonde hair, gray blue eyes, attractive.
Five foot, ten and a half was the way she looked at that white woman behind the counter. This was like, it was like, it was like, it was like, that's what she could do.
It was like she looked at this other white person like she was a piece of dirt and how dare she question, how dare she even think about. I mean, that's the other side of Anne.
She had this, that's a kind of instinct she could get. She could become very, for sure. So, so my, my, my answer to your question is that she loved me.
And the question that I think that she felt that she didn't have to ask anybody's approval. She felt she had the resources in the stature. She felt she was raised in an environment where she was part of the upper class.
So she tended to look down on everybody else. Classic example. And I say this, just as an, classic example. Her best friend was a woman by the name of Damon Estate Estate.
Damon Estate Estate was the daughter of the Dole Pineapple people. They were very, very close friends. Back when I got out of, I was ready to graduate from law school. Damon Estate Estate tried to convince. And we should just move to Hawaii. And I said, you know, I said that. I don't know what I wanted to do. I moved to Hawaii.
I was, she says, look, don't worry about it. We, my family will just, we'll, we'll, we'll, clients and you will build you a house. So forth. You know, we'll just so forth.
And I didn't even appreciate who Damon Estate Estate was until I began to, until Anne began to tell me. And then I began to understand that aside from some king's trust,
aside from the trust in Hawaii that the Damon Estate's are the second largest landowners in Hawaii. And that was Anne's friends.
But those are the, now the other thing was that Anne had lots of left wing friends too. And I think she was.
Well, objectively, I would have to say we were all living in a state of rebellion. But she, more than I, I think, and I loved her. I think she was rebelling against the fact that she did not like her stepfather.
Or really put it very bluntly. She liked her stepfather, but she couldn't reconcile who he was and what he did.
And, and, and one of the arguments we used to have, she thought that I was too nice to him. Or she would say he's only being nice to you because he wants you to overlook. And I said, Anne, hold on.
I said, you're a stepfather. I said, all I know. You know, your mother and, and, and Daniel H. Crena de Iongh, Daniel H. Crena de Iongh, they have their life. They're treating us. So in other words, I, I wanted to defuse it and so forth.
It became very clear, however, that Um Daniel H. Crena de Iongh tended to be more friendly to me than he was to end.
Okay. They had a separate kind of antagonism going on there. But anyway, you asked me to see your question. Well, yeah. I mean, we accepted that as part of the reality. Sometimes that reality would be forced on us, for example.
When we went to Boston and we were looking for a place to live and go to law school, one or two or three places once they found out that we were an interracial couple suddenly the part was not available or something and so forth.
So Anne was not dumb smart. She says, well, this is one apartment that I really like. I think we should have. So what I like to do, let me go and see it. Let me go and look at it.
And if I like it, you trust me. I'm going to come back. I'll show you the diagram. You know, and I'll go back.
And if I like it, you'll have to trust me. We're going to sign. I'm going to take this apartment. You know, and I'll tell them that.
You know, my husband is a student lawyer, but he's and he'll come up and sign the lease later.
Okay. So this is because we've already had to at least two, maybe three instances where we have an apartment fall through.
So finally, I go to this apartment at 857 Beacon Street and as an Irish superintendent and he's a little astounded to see that I am the Mr. Jones.
Okay. That's whom he has rented to his wife. Okay. And he had the stick Irish broke.
And the first thing I said to him, I said, Mr. So-and-so, I said, that broke you have his music to my ears.
I haven't heard that since I was in boarding school with Irish nuns. He looked at me. He says, you were what? I said, yes, I was in boarding school.
And I said, in fact, the one that I had the most love was a Sister Mary Patrician. And she said to me, she made me promise when I grew up, grow up, that I would one day go to the Visitor Island.
And she used to sing to me. She used to sing Danny Boy. And he listened to me. And he said, oh, really?
He says, well, let me show you around the apartment. So I just told him around the apartment and he asked me some questions.
And I told him I had been an altar boy, an altar boy at the midnight mass and at Easter services. And I kept saying how much I owed to the Irish nuns.
And that's why I was so, it was music to my ear to hear that. Well, he said, come on downstairs. I want you to introduce you to my wife.
He's the superintendent of the building now. So his wife is in there. So we take him downstairs and he goes to the refrigerator and he opens up some beers.
We sit and talk. So we have a couple of beers and so forth. And as he's drinking, he's becoming more loose and so forth. He says now.
He says, you know, I think they're probably going to have shit of brick.
This is what he says. They're going to shit of brick when they find out that you're a Negro. But this is my building. I'm the superintendent of this building.
And your wife is signed at least. And I approve of you. And you got a good lease. Welcome to the building.
Okay. Okay. That's okay. That's all right. He then that couple became two of our, they were the superintendent.
And the other thing they liked is that all the other people, all the other tenants in the building, you know, they didn't fraternize with them.
But because he was so nice, my wife would frequently ask them the superintendent of the building to come and have dinner with us, come and do something.
So this man just fell in love with me. You could any fell in love with Anne. Okay. And and and and we used to talk a lot of baseball.
We were, we used to talk about Fenway Park with just a couple of bucks away from my apartment. And and he was, he developed a certain pride in me.
And he was, they used to babysit for us. And he would say, and he would say, you know, he said, you, he said, we were dinner. He says, you know, he said, you know, you know, you're the only, I've never, I've never, I've never sat down and drank with. I never talked to any, I never any talked to any Negro before.
I just never talked to, I don't know why it's a North Turkdom. I don't have anything against them. I just never talked to them. You know, I mean, this is the way he was.
But that's the reason we got that apartment. And so I got that apartment, we got that apartment because of those Irish nuns.
Because I said, I said, when he's broken his broken, it was very distant. I said, she's, I haven't heard that music to my ears. And I so startled her to hear me say that.
And so I said here again, the Irish nuns were looking out for me. I mean, that's how I got.
By the way, it was a magnificent apartment on the top floor of 857 Beacon Street. You see all of it was a number that was like the top floor apartment.
And that's where I went to law school.
And then, I think this is an interest of time, you know, move forward into your entertainment law career.
And then your introduction to Dr. King.
Well, I did, I did, when I was in law school, as I said, a Fran Barrett and Charlie White.
Fran Barrett was my wife's closest friend aside from Damon Estate Estate, who lived in Hawaii.
They moved from Riverside, they moved from New York City to California.
And when they moved to California, my wife began to long. Okay, she really missed them and said, we gotta go out and visit them.
And in my senior year in law school, I took a course in copyright law.
And during that time, copyright law had an essay, a competition called the Nathan Burkan Memorial Copyright Competition,
in which students taking copyright law would write on some esoteric topic.
The country was divided into four Quadrant, the Northeast Quadrants, and so forth.
So in the Northeast Quadrant, it was Harvard, Yale, Boston University, Dartmouth, University of Pennsylvania, Syracuse, and so forth.
Because I was a musician, I wrote a paper called the Judicial Criteria, Employed, to determine musical copyright infringement.
I mean, I wrote the paper showing how the courts, I mean, I did it in renaissance.
The paper didn't win for the Northeast Quadrant, but it got honorable mention.
In other words, there was a winning paper in each quadrant, and then one paper was chosen among the four, but in each quadrant, there was always a second one.
So I got the honorable mention. So my, my, my, my, my copy, my professor was blown away. He says, you know, and since I was a little bit older, I'd gone to law school three years later than if I had just gone from college to law school.
And so we became friendly, you know, we became friendly. It wasn't just professor and student was like, Donald Shapiro, you know, he was professor.
And he's, one day we're having coffee, maybe drinks in and out. He says, you know, Clarence, he says, you really got a real knack for this.
And he says, he says, you know, any entertainment business, he says most Negroes are before the camera or on the footlights or on stages.
And I'm not in any way trying to diminish that talent. He says, but that's not where the real power is. That's not where the decision, the variance in the entertainment business, it's behind.
And I think that's where the people who make the decisions, the people who finance the distribution agreement and so forth. And you got a real knack for this.
And I think you ought to consider going into entertainment law. I have a friend who's a general counsel of Revue Productions, but a name of Leslie Sharlow,
And I'm going to suggest that you go out there and work. And so you go to California. And that's what I did. I went to California to go to work at, as in the office of Leslie Sharlow as in this, you know, just starting out.
I had to take the California bar, which I started to study for, but I had to do, you know.
And in fact, the thing I remember is Sandy Dennis and Bobby Darin, there were two stars.
They used to come sit on my desk in Revue Productions lot. And Bobby Darin had a very kind of openness. He says, now, he says, no, Clarence, where did you come from?
Oh, he says, they don't even, they don't even, they don't even have Negro sleeping at the stages. Where did you come from? You dropped from Mars. How did you get here?
So were you going to talk to less, well, less, less, tell me as you go, we're not as you. Leslie Scharlaw, you know. So they were trying to, they were trying to be a friend me. And Sandy would say, you got to watch your back. Sandy Dennis would say, you know, you got to be, you got to be above.
He says, she would say, you see all these cuties around here. Look at that. You got to be above. Watch your back.
I'm there like three, four months, somewhere between one and six months. Leslie Sharlow dies of a heart attack.
They come all the way out here to go.
So he dies. And he's the power. He's the general counsel. He's the guy. He's Donald Shapiro's friends. So it's like my Godfather's gone.
And people around him and also wonder why is this guy here anyway? You know someone, Leslie Scharlaw is, nobody complained about my work. They complained about my, very clear.
They, very clear. There was very uncomfortable. So I left. And I was thinking about what I was going to do. When I got a call in February, 1960, from Judge Hubert T. Delany,
much of what I'm going to tell you has been repeated. You probably seen interviews. So not verbatim, but a substantial, the same subject matter. I tell people how I met Dr. King.
It's in the book. We read the book. You'll see how I tell. He had been indicted by the state of Alabama for tax evasion for perjury with him.
Judge Hubert T. Delany, Negro judge lawyer, was a chief defense counsel along with three other lawyers. Two of the lawyers were from Chicago. Very elite tax attorneys. The other lawyer was a local lawyer, but they were Fred Gray.
Civil rights, he was a local person. But they needed a law clerk. A clerk who would go down and coordinate. So Judge Hubert T. Delany says, you know, clearance.
I know you and we're defending this. And I'd love for you to come down and be our law clerk and help us with the defense. And I said, Judge, I'd love to do it, but I'm here in Altadena, California. I can't do it. No way I can do that.
No, no, you know, this is a, this is, if you met him, I said, no, he says, well, you know, this is a, this is a very special time, you know, and I might be the, anyway, he made a great, and it was very difficult.
This is the man that recommended me to Boston University of Alaska. This is the person who was a judge, he was a senior. I mean, he was very, very great partner. For me to say no to him, you know, it was, was not easy.
But I said, no, I couldn't, I said, no, for practical purpose, I couldn't go. And so my wife at that time was pregnant with our second child. I was comfortable going.
And you knew obviously my, no, I never met him before. I vaguely heard of him. You know, I tell everybody I was in law school from 1956 and 1959. I didn't know anything. I mean, I knew about the Montgomery bus boycott, but I was studying. I didn't have time to follow the legal feature. What he's doing?
You know, I mean, I was really not focused on that, you know. So the judge was very disappointed in me. The next thing I know it, that was on a Thursday night on Friday morning. I got another call from the judge and he says, Clarence, I did not know it at the time of our conversation.
But Dr. King is on his way to California right now. He has a speaking engagement at the World Affairs Council.
And I told on Saturday evening and I told him, if he does nothing else before he goes through the speaking engagement. And I think he's also going to feature out there. He says, he says, I told him he has to find a way in meeting and talking to you. So I'm thinking to myself, okay, you know what I mean? I'm listening to the judge. And I'm thinking to myself after it.
Why would the judge do that? You know, he's thinking as well. Anyway, maybe just Martin King is going to change my mind. So Friday night doorbell rings. Martin King comes to my home and I'll be in California.
He comes in and he says, you know, he produces himself and comes in with a fellow by the name of Bernard Lee. He comes in to the six around the coffee table on the by the way at that time in February, 1960. Under all classic criteria.
He was a celebrity. He went on the cover of Look, Life, and Time magazines. Plus he had been successful in Montgomery Buzz point got with Rosa Parks. Plus in addition to Supreme Court 1957, it ended down a decision outlawing segregation into state bus transit. He was riding high this feature from Montgomery, okay, in 1960.
So when I told my wife that he was coming, you would have thought in classic current terms that a man of the stature of George Clooney, Denzel Washington, Matt Damon Estate, Matthew McConaughey, Michael Jackson, you know, whoever.
I mean, she was like, oh, you know, the greatest. So she was very impressed. So he sits down and he says, you know, Mr. Jones, we have lots of white lawyers who help us in the movie, but what we need a young Negro.
So I said, Dr. King, I hear you. I said, I told Judge remaining, I'd be willing to work on your case in any way, but I just can't go down. I just can't travel. And then I told him, why, you know, and he asked me some questions about myself and I told him, but I told you about how I was raised, my mother's death and so forth.
I'm shortening it. And he leaves. Now my wife turns to me. And with an unexpected attack dog syndrome. And she says, what do you think you are doing?
That's so important that you cannot help this man that came all this distance to ask for your assistance. I said, hold on. And that's not quite true. He had a speaking engagement. He did not come out to see me.
And besides, because of the new world picture, you got a sand cart in the cooking drawer stealing us, not my problem. Well, that's sort of like center over the top. That's Friday night Saturday night. I got another call this time. The voice is sacramentally sweet.
Mr. Jones, yes, my name is Dora McDonald. You know, Mr. Jones, Dr. King, and joined so much is visited with you and Mrs. Jones, but you know, Mr. Jones, he forgot to invite you to be his guest at a church tomorrow.
He's involved with Hills. He's going to be the guest teacher. And he was so like you and Mrs. Jones to join him. So I told my wife what the message was, she says, well, you may not be going to Montgomery, but you're going to that church.
She didn't want to go. So I go to the church. And I had never heard Dr. King speak before. Never heard him. I mean, they pay attention to him.
I was one third from the front of the full pit. And he gets up. He says, ladies and gentlemen, brothers and sisters, the text of my sermon today, as a role and responsibility of the Negro professional in aiding our less fortunate brothers and sisters, struggling to beat him in the South. So I said, one smart dude.
Then he begins to speak. And he begins to describe what he's doing much more in detail and texturing. I had never heard or seen him speak before.
More accurately, I had never heard another human being walking on two legs on this earth speak that way before. It was mesmerizing. It was like, you know, you could hear a pin drop. And he was, you know, as he was so intense.
And he was so serious. And then he pauses during the course of the sermon. And he says, for example, there's a young man sitting in his church today.
My friends in New York, who are lawyers for whom I have great respect. My friends in New York tell me that this young man's brain has been touched by Jesus.
They tell me that when this young man, a lawyer does any legal research, he goes all the way back to the time of 1066.
We have a conch ran the Magna Carta. And then my friends in New York for whom I have great respect. Tell me that when he writes down what he finds in the law library, the words are so compelling, they just don't want the page.
So I'm thinking to myself, he's not looking at me and I can't even inconceivable he could be talking about me because I'm thinking to myself, I'm a little bit of an opportunist. I'm saying, you know, when this church is over, I want to find out who that man is.
Since I need the network, you know, I'm not a universal picture. I need the network and find out because this brother, this person is going to help me if he's that good.
And then he continues, he said, you know, but I had a chance to visit with this man in his home the other night in Altadena, California. And I said, oh my lord, he started talking about me. Never looking at me.
And then he, I use the example of Roberta Flack as a song killing me softly with your songs. Now what I told Dr. King about myself was not state secrets, but I didn't affect him to tell 1500, 2000 people.
And then he took poetic license that the author, poet Langston Hughes has a poem called, a poem called Mother to Son.
And the lyrics in that poem talk about washable and domestic. She's washing the stairs. She pauses on the landing. She says, I'm doing this for you son. Don't you, don't you give up.
Life ain't been no crystal stair. Don't you give up. Dr. King changes the lyrics and puts my mother as the actor in the poem instead of the washable.
At which point I began to cry because I get disturbed by, you know, I knew that she had begun the greatest pain I've experienced in my life. And then I began to recognize how much.
She loved me. How much she has sacrificed. She didn't see any. She didn't see any other things. She didn't see me graduate from college. She didn't see me graduate from law school. She didn't see me have anything. She was a great teacher.
Surman is over. Dr. King is a celebrity. So he's outstanding autographs on the stuff of the pulpit as I walk over to him. He says, you know, I never meant your name, Mr. Jones, I never meant your name.
He says, sometimes we preach about this.
We need this. I never even mention your name.
I just walked up to him.
Put my hand in his right hand, my right hand in his right hand.
I grabbed his shoulder like this and I said,
Dr. King, when do you want me to go to Montgomery, Alabama?
That was a major turning point in my life.
And then, now we're rolling.
Okay, today is April 16, 2013.
Right, you got today's address correct.
Okay, yesterday you had an incorrect, right?
Yes, I knew we were going to end up on a second day.
Okay. Today is April 16, 2013.
We're continuing with Dr. Clarence Jones here in California.
Dr. Clarence B. Jones.
Clarence B. Jones, you're in Hawaii.
Thank you again for spending even more time with us.
What we'd like to do because time is limited.
Of the essence, right?
Is jump ahead a little bit to the background of the March on Washington
and preparing Dr. Lisa Marx.
Okay.
So if you could tell us a little bit about how you all planned for that
and how that, how his speech came about and what went into it
from behind the scenes.
Okay.
Did I set the backdrop about what was happening in the months
following the Birmingham Children's Crusade of the March on Washington?
The bottom line is that the success in Birmingham became the spark
that ignited a prairie fire of non-violent protests across the country.
Between May and late August, 1963,
there were over 1,300+ demonstrations, 200 cities, 36 states.
Okay.
Dr. King, we recognize that something qualitatively had happened.
It was happened to the country.
So when the civil rights organizations announced at the Roosevelt Hotel in June
that they were going to hold on March on Washington,
I was surprised.
And one of the things I was surprised is because I knew that Dr. King had been exhausted.
He had been in jail for eight days in Birmingham.
Then he had a big rally in Detroit, Michigan.
And I was surprised that he would so readily consent.
And apparently he didn't consent.
He was slated to go on a vacation with his wife and children
as he customary does to either the Bahamas or Jamaica.
And it became clear to me, I wasn't part of the discussion,
but it became clear that that's what he was thinking about doing.
Stanley Levison and Bayard Rustin as they hold on Dr. King, you can't go.
You need to stay here.
And what we'll do is we'll give you a vacation in the states
and we'll ask Clarence and his wife to vacate their newly constructed homes.
So that you and your family can stay there.
The only problem is nobody asked, nobody talked to me.
Okay? So the next thing I know is that Stanley Levison says that he and Bayard,
and others have decided that we had to leave our home so that's Coretta
and Dr. King and their poor children could stay in our house.
And the principal political reason was that we would have access to him domestically.
And he would be able to have a vacation while still being available
from Washington Washington.
And so during that period of time, he was writing a book, among other things,
and during that period of time, Stanley Levison and I, particularly,
even though again two months earlier on June 22nd,
Stanley had been the subject of a private conversation between President Kennedy.
And Dr. King.
And that conversation very directly was that the president told him
that he had to get rid of Stanley Levison and Jack O'Dell
that they had reliable information with the FBI.
Stanley Levison was a high ranking member of the Communist Party,
and so was Jack O'Dell.
And so that was like a time bomb.
Not a time bomb was like a meager explosion that somewhat derailed
things at the point, but the point is, as the march approached,
Stanley and I can, although it was decided that Stanley would step back
with his consent, with his urging.
Dr. King did not want to reduce his oral context of Stanley.
He did not want to sever a direct army.
He was very much adamant again.
But Stanley, his attitude was, listen, the movement you're leading is more important.
And me or the relationship you and I have.
This is what the president, Attorney General, want, let's give it to him,
let's move on.
We have more important things to do.
But meanwhile, Stanley and I talked virtually every day,
and Matt is involving Dr. King.
And at some point in those discussions, what he would say at the march came up.
And the question was really a policy question.
What kind of speech, you know, you're going to give a public sermon.
You're going to give a political treatise of what kind of speech you're going to make.
What's the one from the beginning that he would be the last speaker of the day?
Oh no, no, no, no, you asked it.
You asked the question that maybe you don't know how pregnant it is with controversy.
Okay, as a matter of fact, there were, there came a time
when conservative clergymen in the March committee, through the organizations,
they wanted, they put a proposal out that there should be ex number speakers,
let's say 12 speakers or 10 speakers, and each should have no more than eight minutes.
And they had proposed that Dr. King be in the middle.
And I heard this, I heard that this is going to be a proposal.
When I heard this, and by Bayard Rustin who shared this with me,
and I persuaded Dr. King, I don't want you to come to this meeting of the march committee.
It's better that you not come.
And I'm listening.
And they said, well, we think that this is the way it should be and so forth.
And I clearly got the sense that there was an effort, I'm not sure other than Ego what the reason was,
that they wanted to marginalize Dr. King.
They didn't, they wanted to prevent him from being the last speaker.
And they didn't, and they wanted to marginalize him.
So Dr. King wasn't there, so I could say things that he certainly wouldn't say at this meeting.
And who is there? Who is there?
They is a bad Russian, Walter Reuther, a yes, wired worker, A. Philip Randolph, a Cleveland Robinson,
a representative from the UAW, representatives from a core, representatives of student on violent coordinate committee, representatives from the NAACP,
and representatives of several of the local black churches and representatives from the diocese, the Catholic diocese in the year, okay?
And someone from the American Jewish Congress.
But the black clergy representatives were the ones who were trying to manipulate the power in my observation.
They made a proposal that the each person be allowed the same amount of speech and they had proposed that Dr. King be in the middle of that.
So while this discussion is going on, I just said, excuse me, gentlemen, I said,
you've all heard Dr. King speak, have you, have you, have all of you in this room heard Dr. King speak?
Well, tell me something, do you really want to, do you really want to follow Dr. King?
I said now in my, when I'm not doing civil rights work, I said I have a law practice with two other partners,
and we do a lot of entertainment, working with representatives of all artists and performing artists.
And I said in the concert business, in the concert business, there's something called an opening act and a major act.
And I said, do you really want to follow Dr. King?
And I said, well, why do you say that? I said, well, because quite frankly, you're in the risk that after he speaks, I just turned it off.
After he speaks, people will, so with some, with some begrudging consent, and what tip the discussion was a Phil Randolph.
Because yes, I think that, I think that brother Martin should come, and I agree with, I agree with Clarence Jones, most of these people.
And I don't want to offend anybody in this room, but most of the people are coming from all over the country.
They're coming to hear Dr. King, and we should have him as a last speaker.
And the preparation of the speech was, some people think that Dr. King, the Washington, is set down and just going to write the speech.
He was at the Willard Hotel, working on his speech, but the speech he was working on, incorporated, or I provided him with information, that he could use, if he chose to.
In the speech that he was preparing. I did not know, until I was standing 50 feet behind him, and he actually spoke.
And I listened very carefully. I did not know that after his perfunctory interuptory remarks, that as he began speaking,
the first opening, six or seven paragraphs or more, with the draft paragraphs, which I put in summary form for him to use.
Whether he was tired, whether he liked it, or whether he just, he was pressed for time, but he didn't change his sentence.
Not a word, a paragraph, or a comma. He spoke verbatim. What I had prepared, but what I had prepared was a summary of what we had discussed several times about the kind of things that he should say.
I just used a certain degree of drama because I had had the problem of raising bail money. I had to go in the bail money, and I remember going to the Chase Manhattan Bank, to raise some bail money coming up to New York and going in and seeing money from Florida's ceiling.
And so when I was drafted, this I said, I can't believe, drafted the suggested paragraph, the language I said, I can't believe that we have assembled here today to redeem the promissory note, to which the signers of the Declaration of Independence were heirs.
And what's the present generation, is an air to this promissory note, I cannot believe that in the vaults of justice in the United States that the bank of justice insufficient funds.
So he's speaking. That's the first time I had an idea that he was going to incorporate the actual suggested language, had no idea until then.
Because your normal process is you give him a draft and you'd work with this.
Yeah, yeah, right, right, right, right, right, right, right. And this is the normal process too. He didn't use everything. He didn't use all of the paragraphs, but he used the first six or seven of the paragraphs, and then he added his own paragraphs.
And then as he is speaking from this written, paired text, his favorite gospel singer, Mahalia Jackson, shout-out to him. She had performed earlier on the program.
Tell him about the dream, Martin, tell him about the dream. And I'm watching him. And in real time, he acknowledges her. But then he takes the prepared written text and moves it to the left side of the lectern and grabs the left side of the lectern and starts to speak.
And I turned to the person sitting next to me, who were standing next to me, whoever that person was, that they're still living.
I said, these people don't know it, but they're about ready to go to church. And I said that because I saw Dr. King's body language change.
So that the part of the speech, that speech, that the nation in the world celebrates the so-called I have a dream speech, was completely spontaneous, was completely extemporaneous.
And but for the last part, where he's looking at notes in the end about this Negro, he was quoting a poem about a new free and last free at last, which is a, which is a, from a, from a Protestant clergyman many years earlier, everything else was spontaneous, everything.
Now, as I say in my book, behind the dream, the baking of the speech, the transformation. You know, I heard Martin King and saw him speak many times.
I'm not suggesting, well, whatever your belief, whatever your religious belief, if any, whatever your belief in spirituality or transcendentalism, if any, I can only tell you what I experienced and what I saw.
And what I experienced and what I saw, I had never up until that time in my life, anyone, including Dr. King, I had never heard Dr. King speak that way before.
It is as if some cosmic, powerful force came down and took over his body, that there was the same body I was looking at, but something had taken it over.
Because the words, the way he said it, was so powerful. And I think it was the combination of the beauty of the day, two or three o'clock in the afternoon, the beauty of the day, the citus, the venue, the Lincoln Memorial,
the more than 250,000 people you have to sign at that time, no place in America had that many people ever assembled in one place at one time.
Peacefully, 25% of whom were white, no place. And something happened in the interaction between what Martin was saying in that audience, so that never, ever again,
until he is a, never again in his lifetime, had I ever heard him speak that way. Now people will say, well, you know, he gave a very moving speech in April 3rd, 1968 in Mason Temple, moving speech, depressed, talk about I've been to the mountain top, in terms of the political content, well, a lot of from the Birmingham Jail was much more profound political statement.
Beyond Vietnam" speech, A Time to Break Silence much more political profound statement on non-violence both internationally and nationally.
But the power of his simple message, because he was calling for America, he was summoning America's conscience, so that the nation could be as good as it was intended to be.
I don't know whether I've said this to you before, but the genius of Martin Luther King, Jr., the political genius was that he knew, and we knew, that no matter how compelling and how fair the case for any racial segregation was on his merits, there was no way the 12% of the population was going to impose that point of view, nobody how fair and compelling on the merits.
On 88% of the population was going to happen, in spite of our friends on the black left and the white left who said, the only way to only think the white man understands is a gun and a kick in a butt.
Anyone who wanted to cancel violence on the part of 12% of the population against 88% of the population is counseling political suicide.
Yes, we were students of the end of the revolution of the end of the developed country, we were students of the Algeria, Zimbabwe, Kenya, Ghana, Egypt, we understood.
But we understood the peculiarities of the American experience.
So therefore, the genius of Martin Luther King was that he would summon the conscience of America through peaceful, non-violent confrontation with racial segregation, so that the conscience of the 88% of the country,
would be forced to see the contradiction between the way in which it treated 12% of its people, people of color, and the command the mints in the Declaration of Independence and our Constitution.
But guess what? To Dr. King, it wasn't a constitutional or legal question for America. It was a moral question.
And he raised the level, he raised in the level of the 88% raised the question in their minds, is whether this is the kind of nation they want to be.
Is it morally right to deny 12% of the population full access to equal protection of the laws, equal opportunity for both solely based on the color of the skin?
That was his political genius.
I guess I told you the phrase from the boys about the lions don't tell this story, I've told you that.
I think it's important for future generations that they be unambiguously clear as to the power and the meaning of the nation.
Of the I have a gene speech in the March on Washington.
I don't want people to get caught up in the so-called nostalgia of commemorating the 50th anniversary of the March,
and overlook the centrality of what that was about.
Was it the greatest speech in terms of political content? I don't think so.
But what Martin King did, is that I talk about him having taken America on a journey to overcome.
He had to appreciate the commemoration of Martin King's 50th anniversary.
He had to understand what happened, what America was going through.
It was America going through America had become like a dysfunctional alcoholic or drug addict.
It had become addicted on racial segregation dependency.
And it tried unsuccessfully to break its addiction and dependency.
And Martin King took America conscience by the hand and said, I'm going to take you on a road of peaceful, redemptive recovery to recover your soul.
And I'm going to do this non-violently. I'm going to do it, telling you I love you every step of the way.
I'm going to do it to let you know no matter what you say to me, no matter what you do to me.
You can call me all sorts of names. You can put me in jail. You can bomb my house. You can threaten me.
But at the end of all those things, I'm still going to love you.
Because my compassion and love for your soul and for you to redeem,
the best of what this country, to be my compassion, my commitment to do that, is greater than you're greater and stronger than anything you can do to me.
Greater than stronger. Because I believe in you, America.
You may not believe in yourself, but I can believe in you. And so that when I tell you I have a dream, I'm not speaking about the present tense.
I'm speaking prophetically in the future. I know I have absolute confidence.
Not now, maybe on August 28th, 1963. But I believe that one day, my four children, I may be alive, I may not be alive.
We may not be around, you don't know, but one day, this country that I believe in, my four children will be judged by the content of their character and not by the color of their skin.
It may not be happening today, it may not happen tomorrow, it may not happen in your lifetime or my lifetime.
But one day, your conscience will come to see the immorality of racial segregation, the immorality of racism.
So that one day, the great great grand sons of slaves and the great great grand sons of slave owners will sit, will sit down one day at the table of brotherhood.
I believe that that will happen, America. Even though you may at this time, may not believe in yourself.
That's, you want to commemorate the 50th anniversary of Martin King, that's what you got to remember.
You got to remember, in 1963, Martin King in Birmingham put a moral stake in the ground.
They know on the top that stake was a moral compass.
Okay? And that a moral compass became a moral compass.
And what he did was to show the way of how we have got to live up to be the best that we can be in.
Otherwise, the country is not going to be governable.
It's not a question of white people having power over white people.
It's not a question of white people having power over black people.
It's a question of co-equally participating in a power based on the indestructible commitment to the uniqueness of the speciality and dignity of the human personality.
Everybody, everybody is somebody.
So that in 2013, when I hear, particularly people from the African-American conservative church community,
tell me that it's against God's will, that homosexuality is a sin. It's against God's will.
And I am never going to be in support of same-sex marriage. I'm never going to be in support. Homosexuality is a sin.
So I say to them, I was raised in a Christian religious principle. And I was raised to believe that we were all created in God's image.
So tell me those of you who are so opposed to the LGBT people, isn't it funny that God must really love gay and lesbian people?
Because otherwise, why would he keep creating so many of them? I arrest my case.
The commemoration of this anniversary is a commemoration to America's quintessential pre-immun and a puzzle of nonviolence.
And just as the nation had to deal with asking itself, what kind of people are we when it looked at, on the front pages of his newspapers, of firehows or slamming little black boys and girls against the walls, Birmingham, Alabama, or police dogs against black boys and girls who are demonstrating peacefully?
Just as the nation had to ask itself, what kind of nation are we that we would do this?
After Newtown, Connecticut, when you have 20 babies and 16 adult schools, you want to commemorate the Fiftieth Anniversary of Martin King's legacy, knowing that he was the pre-eminent apostle of nonviolence.
You have to ask yourself, what kind of nation are we that we would prevent this to happen?
So I don't know what different people are going to be doing on the 28th of August, 2013 in Birmingham and Cleveland, Ohio and Washington D.C., and Philadelphia and all the nations throughout all the countries and communities across this nation.
But I can tell you one thing, there can be no more true commemoration, to a legacy than if this nation like the executive in the movie Network.
If a vote will be majority of American people on the 28th of August, 2013 saying enough is enough.
I'm mad as hell and I'm not going to take it anymore". Violence is destroying this great country.
It would be a sacrilege to go through the motions of commemorating his legacy without tying the legacy to the existential violence that is in our country today, the ubiquitous presence of violence.
And we can do something about it. We can do something about it.
Martin King would say, come on America, you're better than this. We don't have to continue gun violence.
We don't have to continue racial segregation. We can end it if we want to.
So I don't want to hear, we should overcome and I don't want to hear all these commemorative songs.
What is going to be done? 24-7, August 28, 2013 to deal with the question of the ubiquitous violence that is affecting our young people particularly.
And the unevenness of the effects of that violence. In some cases, read readily, it has to be clinically described as black on black violence.
What do I mean? I mean by young black people, men, using guns to kill one another over some failed drug deal or over somebody stepped on their sneakers
or some crazy nonsense.
You want to honor the memory of Dr. King's I have a dream speech.
Then you have the courage to recognize the fundamental qualitative changes that have taken place in many of the households in the African-American community.
And that is the substantial destruction of the family structure with a male house, a male in the house on a constant basis.
I'm not talking about husband and wife, I'm talking about a responsible male, responsible female.
So that for example, here in San Francisco, you have an organization called the Omega Boys Club.
And by Dr. Joseph Marshall Jr, he recognizes this. He recognizes that if you ever want to have a chance of saving the generation of Caribbean over youth, you've got to find a substitute equivalent to the parental structure of discipline which they don't have.
So that in effect, the programs he offers at the Boys Club is the program of parental or adult structure discipline that they don't get at home.
But that adult structure, difficult, is enough to keep them alive and free.
So I was once having a discussion with Dr. Marshall, which I said, you know, Joe, the most important days in the most important historical days in the history of the African-American nation, African-American people, 1619 in the United States, in 1863, the Emancipation Proclamation, he said, no, no, no, clients.
You omitted a very important day, and he says, what said he says, 1980, I said, what happened in 1980? Is that some crack cocaine is introduced into the African-American community? That's so fundamentally changed.
To be a good teacher, Dr. King once said to me, you not only need to know your scripture, and you need to be conversant with the underlying teachings, but you have to have the ability to tell your audience a story.
You got to tell the story, and the story can be any number of things. The story can be about redemption, redemption, the story can be about, but you got it. You got to tell a story to people can buy into.
So I am suggesting for those people who listen and read about this time in American history, as we approach the 50th anniversary of the I have a dream speech, that the story of this generation is the story of this extraordinary man who sought to save the soul of America. That's the story.
Unfortunately, I am about 5-1 minute.
We allow us to sign, I am going to sign, so you can go.
What are the parts of Dr. King's journey, as you are talking about his journey and his legacy? Do we need to honor, as we think about him at this time, for the African-American anniversary?
Are there other works such as his anti-Hiswar?
No, no, no, no, no, what you have to honor is his unshakable commitment to end the inequity of wealth disparity.
At the time of his assassination, he was working the template that he was involved in, of course, was Memphis sanitation workers' strike, but that was just an template of an example to highlight the issue of wealth and income disparity in this nation.
Ironically, the movement of Occupy Wall Street, that's what it was about.
That's what it was about, and by the way, this was not a movement of impoverished black people.
This is not a movement of impoverished white people. This is a movement of largely middle class, principally white people, who somehow began to see that there's something very unfair about a system of which they play by all of the rules.
They go and get a good education. They keep themselves out of trouble, and they try to apply their skills, and they recognize that even if they do everything that they've asked to be done, they're going to have at best a marginal participation in the benefits of this country.
And that's not morally right.
Listen to me. That's not morally right.
So what other things should we think about as legacy? He's unshakable. Come here.
What prompted his opposition, public opposition to the war in Vietnam, was not only his opposition and the test of the application of violence on an international scale, but he was not stupid.
He recognized that no matter what Lyndon Johnson said in his heart about the war in poverty, there was no way that a war in poverty can be fought when you're taking the resources, the dollars of the treasury of the United States, and you're taking those dollars to buy armaments.
But there's no way. There's no way. So it's a sham.
So again, if you the reason he opposed the war was a moral reason. He realized aside from his absolute opposition, the violence he realized that it was, it was just impossible.
It was politically and economically impossible for the president of the United States to utter well-meaning words about fighting property when there was no money to do it. It was being spent to kill North Vietnamese.
So that's the other part of his legacy. And of course, militarism.
I think, and this is controversial because it's my interpretation, I'm asked directly, what do I think Martin King would say about same six-minute American? I said, I don't know in fact what he would say.
But I can interpret his body of work. And I can interpret what I think he would say. And I think he would come down on what I said earlier, whether people would say, well, homosexuality is a sin, so what I think Martin could be on any such.
It's not about all the things you object to. It's about an elementary thing called love and compassion. Remember the principle, founding injunction of his Christianity was love, that's what it was founded on. Love, the enemy.
So I'm very pleased that you spent this time with me.
Thank you so much. It was one of those really.
Okay, this is one lion that wanted to tell a story so that the Hunters won't get all the credit.
Thank you. I may have this. Yeah. I have a pen.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.